what was it like returning to this movie
three decades later you know a lot of
questions have to be answered and like
you know a lot of that is provided by
the director and the writer and you know
who am i working with on this it's going
to give a fresh vision to it and once I
knew that I knew we were contemporize
events we were going back essentially to
the tenpo moments for the original
animated movie and we were adding a new
song for Jasmine and you know once I
knew that that our path was kind of set
when you scored this film this
adaptation did you use any old bits or
ideas that you had the difference yes
yes we we did a number of touch tones to
the original movie you know just number
one because that part of the score
number two because it kind of gives
subtle reminders to the audience of what
experienced 27 years ago and it's all
about keeping that thread unbroken did
you work hands-on with any of the new
actors to sort of develop the
arrangements that just suited there
really no I think in the case of wills
Will Smith's came in and just made it
his own and I just said okay let's go
man and let me just support what he did
with the arrangement with with both Mina
and Naomi melasma and jasmine aladdin
and Jasmine they were very faithful to
what I wrote and I have a great music
team on the ground in London because you
know I'm in New York and they're in
London so the team is very responsible
for keeping them true to what I wrote
and they're wonderful they you know they
just did what but I what I wrote and
then made it come to life even Howard
Ashman were a huge part of the Disney
Renaissance I mean for a lot of people
myself included who grew up with those
movies your name is sort of inseparable
from Disney what do you imagine you
would be doing if you hadn't decided to
work with Disney oh my god well at one
point I wanted to be a pop singer I'm
singer/songwriter I
I would have pursued that I don't know
Howard I probably would have written
more musicals but I think it was I think
it was fate the truth be told I just
think it was destiny and it had to be so
it's hard to me to even imagine an
alternative okay
of the music that you've written for
Disney what's your favourite piece oh
god my least favourite question because
they're all my children that you know I
can't I there's no way I could say that
you know I can say which is the most
successful or which is you know the one
that's sort of the lost gem or which is
the one I love to perform at parties or
whatever it is but they all have their
own unique stand okay well what about
one you didn't write oh yeah and I wish
I've written oh my god oh my god maybe
the second star to the right I don't
know yeah seconds time you know the
feeling that I get from they also said I
grew up with this generation if you have
think you know listening to my songs
that they grew up with so it's that
really when you hear something at that
age it just really gets into your heart
okay
do you think the genie sings that song
to everybody that ropes the lamp for the
first time I would like to think not I
would like to think it's only for
Aladdin it would be kind of this
important could be saying that too like
Jafar or something I think she'd
probably just slap them thank you so
much for your time it's over thank you
great thank you